[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير مشاهدينا
نحييكم الى الخامسه نناقش فيها مجموعه من
المواضيع وتفاصيل هذه المواضيع من خلال
هذه العناوين
[موسيقى]
بوتينو سعد ضد الغربي اعلان استمرار
المواجهه وتعليق المشاركه في معاهده
الاسلحه الاستراتيجيه
[موسيقى]
وعشان طنطوا دينوا خطاب بوتين العدائي
للغرب وبايدن ينسق في بولندا خطط لدعم
اوكرانيا
يرفع شعار المحاسبه بعد كارثه الزلزال
المدمر وعشرون الف لاجئ سوري يعودون
لبنتهم
وبعد اوروبا وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه يقول
ان الكره في ملعب ايران للتواصل بشان
البرنامج النووي
ونحييكم مشاهدينا الى التفاصيل سنبداها من
تطورات الحرب الاوكرانيه حيث اعلن رئيس
روسيا فلاديمير بوتين تعليق روسيا
لمشاركتها في معاهده الاسلحه الاستراتيجيه
مؤكدا استمرار موسكو في تطوير العمليه
العسكريه في اوكرانيا وقال بوتين خلال
كلمه امام البرلمان بمناسبه مرور عام على
الحرب قال ان اوكرانيا لم تترك لروسيا اي
خيارا سوى القيام بعمليه عسكريه وكشف
الرئيس الروسي عن ارسال ضمانات امنيه
للولايات المتحده ولحلف الناتو قبلت
بالرفض حيث حمل بوتين الدول الغربيه
مسؤوليه ارتفاع عدد ضحايا الصرع وحول طول
امد الحرب قال رئيس روسي ان الغرباء اعد
اوكرانيا لحرب طويله الامد
ليس فقط في الولايات المتحده بل كذلك في
بريطانيا وفرنسا وجميعها موجهه ضد روسيا
يجب ان نضع ذلك في الاعتبار في الظرف
الراهن لذلك روسيا ستعلق مشاركتها في
معاهده الاسلحه الاستراتيجيه والهجوميه
واذا قامت الولايه المتحده باجراء تجارب
نوويه فنحن سنقوم بالمثل اي حديث عن
الاخلال بنظام الردع النووي غير صحيح
نحن منفتحون على الحوار البناء مع الغرب
واكدنا ان اوروبا والعالم بحاجه الى الامن
غير المجزا لكن الرد كان خادعا انها تتوسع
واقترب من حدودنا وتم نشر القواعد
العسكريه ليست لاي دوله كهذا العدد من
القواعد العسكريه الموجوده لدى الولايات
المتحده اؤكد ان لديها المئات ويكفي ان
ننظر الى الخريطه لقد تخلوا عن اتفاقيات
التسليح ونسف السلام انهم لا يقومون باي
شيء عبثا في ديسمبر 2021 ارسلنا الى
الولايات المتحده والناتو ضمانات للامن
وردوا بالرفض حينها اتضح انهم يملكون خططا
عدائيه
[موسيقى]
وفي اول رد اوكرانيه على خطاب بوتين قال
مستشار رئاسه الاوكرانيه ميخائيل ان بوتين
ظهر منفصلا عن الواقع بحسب تعبيره واضاف
ان بوتين مرتبك ولا يحق له الحديث عن
القانون او العداله
وفي هذا الاطار لم يختلف كثيرا الموقف
الامريكي عن نظيره الاوكراني حيث وصفت
الاداره الامريكيه خطاب بوتين بانه معاد
للغرب وسخيف وقال مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي
بان الغرب هدد روسيا لغز اوكرانيا سخيفه
واضاف ان روسيا لم تتعرض لاي شكل من اشكال
التهديد العسكري سواء من اوكرانيا او اي
بلد اخر والفتاه الى ان خطاب بايدن من
بولندا لن يتضمن اي نوع من الخطط لانهاء
الحرب عبر الدبلوماسيكا
وحول تعليقي موسكو مشاركتها في معاهده
ستارت وصف وزير الخارجيه الامريكان بانه
قرار غير مسؤول ومؤسف للغايه وقال ان
واشنطن ستراقب تحركات روسيا عن كسب لمعرفه
خطواتها المقبله مشيرا الى استعداد واشنطن
في الحوار حول معاهده نوستارت في اي وقت
هذا وكانت وصفات ريست الحكومه الايطاليه
جورجيا ميلونيا التي وصلت الى كياف صباح
اليوم وصفت خطاب بوتين بانه مجرد دعايه
واشارت الى انها كانت تنتظر من بوتين
خطابا مغايرا نحو انهاء الحرب وسبق ان
وعدت مليونيره وصلت الى اوكرانيا على متن
قطار من بولندا انها ستزور اوكرانيا قبل
ذكرى الاولى لبدء الغزو الروسي في الرابع
والعشرين من فبراير
في غضون ذلك عبر الامين العام لحلف الناتو
عن القلق من احتمال امداد الصين روسيا
باسلحه لحربها في اوكرانيا مكررا في ذلك
الموقف الامريكي وحمل سولتنبرغ الرئيس
الروسي بوتين مسؤوليه الحرب وتمسكه
بالتصعيد مشيرا لان خطابه يؤكد انه يستعد
لحرب اوسع وابدا سفه لقرار بوتين تعليق
مشاركه موسكو في معاهده الاسلحه
الاستراتيجيه والهجوميه داعيا اياه الى
اعاده النظر في هذا القرار
نناقش هذه التطورات مع ضيفنا من القاهره
احمد عليبه الباحث في وحده الدراسات
الامنيه والعسكريه في مركز الاهرام
للدراسات السياسيه الاستراتيجيه اهلا بك
معنا استاذ احمد استاذ احمد اتفاق مهم
نتحدث عن ستارت ذلك الاتفاق الذي تعدى
تعهد به الطرفان واشنطن من جهه وموسكو من
جهه اخرى بتخفيض الاسلحه النوويه بوتين
يعلن عن تعليقه عمليا ما الذي يعنيه ذلك
يعني مبدئيا لابد من ان نشير الى انه
الالتزامات الخاصه
بالاتفاقيه نيو ستارت كانت معلقه منذ فتره
طويله من الناحيه العمليه لانه ليس فقط في
فتره الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا ولكن قبل
ذلك روسيا كانت قد يعني تزرعت بانه خلال
فتره ازمه كورونا كان هناك صعوبه
لتفعيل اليه لجان التفتيش تعطلت اكثر من
اربعين عمليه لجنه تفتيش ايضا الانعقاد
السنوي للجنه
اللجنه الثنائيه المشتركه الخاصه
بالاستراتيجيه ومراجعه
الاتفاقيه بشكل اساسي بتنعقد مرتين في
العام ايضا جمهوريه خلال تلك الفتره
تقريبا اكثر من ست اجتماعات وبالتالي
الالتزامات كانت معلقه الان اصبحت
الاتفاقيه نفسها معلقه هذا يعني ان هذه
الاتفاقيه لن تصمد كثيرا وانه هناك خلف
هذا القرار ربما وجهات نظر سياسيه او ربما
هناك مسائل ابرام صفقات سياسيه
خلال فتره
ولكن حضرتك لما تقول بانه هذه الاتفاقيه
شابه تاريخها بعض الاختلافات بعض التوترات
بعض الجمود والبرود ولكن تعليقها في هذه
المرحله بطريقه صريحه وواضحه من الجانب
الروسي في فتره كما تعلم حضرتك تشهد تصعيد
في الداخل الاوكراني وتصعيد كذلك حتى بين
الدول الكبرى واشنطن وموسكو هل هذا سيفتح
المجال لتصعيد من شكل اخر
بالتاكيد يعني هناك مؤشرات لهذا التصعيد
خاصه فيما يتعلق بالملف النووي لانه هناك
متغيرات حصلت فيما يتعلق بهذا الاتفاقيه
على وجه التحديد لانه روسيا عملت قبل
مساله التعليق على تحديث الثالوث النووي
الولايات المتحده منخرط في هذا الامر كان
هناك خلافات كثيره حول انه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه في نهايه عهد الرئيس
ترامب كانت تريد ان تنضم الصين الى هذا
الاتفاقيه الان الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين يتحدث عن المظله النوويه ليس فقط عن
الاتفاق النووي بمعنى حينما يشير الى
فرنسا
وبريطانيا وغيرها من دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
التي تمتلك اولا مخزون نووي امريكي يقدر
بحوالي 100 قنبله نوويه بالاضافه الى
مشاريعها النوويه ايضا المرتبطه بهذا
السياق فهو يتحدث عن المظله النوويه التي
يعني الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تتمتع
بها حوالي 30 دوله تقريبا من جانب
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هذا التشابك
الذي يطرحه على الرئيس بوتين اليوم هو
يريد ان يدخل اتفاقيه في سياق اخر مختلف
للمساومه ربما ايضا على ما يتعلق
بالحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه حينما اثار
مساله
دعم العسكري الذي يقدم للجانب الاوكراني
وبالتالي ان يساول من اكثر من جهه يعني
الجهه الاولى هي مساله انه العوده الى
التلويح وان الملف النووي لا يزار حاضرا
على
لا يزال حاضرا في مشهد هذه الحرب وبالتالي
هو يستدعي هذا الملف في الذكرى الاولى
لاندلاع هذه الحرب المساله الاخرى انه
ايضا يلوح بمساله انه القواعد اللعبه التي
كانت تحكم هذه الاتفاقيه قد تغيرت وانه لم
يعد
بمقدور روسيا ان تستمر وفقا لتلك القواعد
وان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ايضا
وحلفائها اتهامهم الرئيس بوتين بانهم ايضا
سعوا الى تغيير قواعد اللعبه خلال تلك
الفتره السابقه التاليه نعم تصور انه
القدمه ستاتي بالكثير من الجديد كذلك بحسب
حتى قراءه ولو ان فتل لم يتحدث عن او لم
يصرح بشكل واضح في كلمته المنتظره ولكن
كما قلت حضرتك استاذ احمد
تعليق هذه الاتفاقيه قد ياتي بجديد سنتابع
هذا الموضوع اود شكرا جزيلا شكرا للمشاركه
وكل ما تفضلت به من القاهره احمد علي
بالباحث في وحده الدراسات الامنيه
والعسكريه في مركز الاهرام للدراسات
السياسيه والاستراتيجيه شكرا لك
مع مرور عام على اعلان بوتين اعتراف بلاده
باستقلال
دونيتين في اوكرانيا لا تزال المعارك على
الارض لم تحسم يبدو ان احد اهداف بوتين
للحرب لا يزال معلقا بعد فشل السيطره على
المنطقتين لتين تشكلان معا اقليم الدومباس
لم يتوقف الامر عند هذا الحد حيث يظهر في
الخلفيه خلافا او خلافا بين القاده او بدا
واضح بين القاده العسكريين الروس ومجموعه
فاغنر المدعومه من بوتين والتي تقود
المعارك في شرق البلاد منذ اشهر بوتين
الذي اعلن في سبتمبر الماضي رسميا ضمه
لوجان سكوادونيسك بالاضافه الى زابوريجا
وخرسون قال ان سكان هذه المناطق اصبحوا
مواطني روسيا والى الابد مع ذلك الاوضاع
على الارض افسدت او افسدت ولو مؤقتا خطط
السيد الكريم الرميه لبسط السيطره على
المناطق
مدينه بخموت كذلك الواقعه في دنيا مثلا
وهي اكثر جبهات القتال اشتعالا حيث تقع
اشتباكات ضاريه بينما تسعى موسكو الى
احراز اول انتصار رئيسي لها في الميدان
منذ صيف 2022 باتت ضخمه رمزا للمقاومات
الاوكرانيه اما على الجانب الاخر يبدو ان
تكتيكات الحرب ليست فقط وراء عدم تقدم
فاجنر فبالنسبه لقائدها يافقيني بريغوزين
ارجع ذلك الى وجود مشكله كبيره كما قال في
امدادات الذخيره لقواته وسط خلاف عام مع
عقده الجيش بريكوزين هجم وزير الدفاع
الروسي ورئيس الاركان وقال انهما يحاولان
حرمان قواته من الضخائر واصفا ذلك
بالخيانه
يصدر رئيس الاركان ووزير الدفاع امرا بعد
امر يمنع تقديم الذخيره
ومساعدتها في النقل الجوي جاء المعلومات
للتو تفيد بانهم رفضوا حتى امدادنا بمجارف
حتى لا يتمكن الرجال من الحفر هناك ببساطه
معارضه مباشره ومستمره وهي ليست سوى
محاوله لتدمير يمكن ان يقارن هذا بالخيانه
العظمى الان عندما تقاتل فاغنر من اجل
باخمت وتفقد المئات من مقاتليها كل يوم
ومشاهدينا في تطورات الوضع المدني ايضا
اتهم رئيس الاوكرانيه
بقصف المدنيين بلا رحمه وذلك بعدما اعلن
الجيش الاوكراني مقتل سته مدنيين واصابه
اكثر من عشره اخرين في قصف الروسي على
خرسون واشار الى ان القوات الروسيه تقصف
خرسون بقوه وسادفت مناطق سكنيه ومحطه نقل
عام
نذكر باننا قبل ايام قليله من ذكرى السنه
على بدايه هذه الحرب وفي هذا الاطار نسال
مفردين الى كل من كياف مفردات العربيه
ليال الاختيار ومن خركيز
اهلا بكم زملائي الاعزاء واسمح لي ان ابدا
من كياف معك ليال ليال سنه كما تعلمين على
بدايه هذه الحرب كيف تبدو اولا الصوره
العامه من حولك كيف يتابع الناس طول امد
هذه الحرب فيما توقعها البعض قصيره او
متوسطه الامد هي مستمره
نعم نعم ريما اهلا بك وبالمشاهدين الكرام
يعني اليوم
وفور وصولنا الى كياف قمنا بجوله على بعض
المناطق والاحياء وخصوصا المناطق التي
سقطت فيها اولى الصواريخ الروسيه على
المدينه بهذا التوقيت يعني قبل ايام منذ
سنه بالذات على هذه المناطق
الواضح كما تشاهدين خلفي بالصوره ان
الحياه الطبيعيه بكياف الناس تعيش حياه
طبيعيه بالرغم من ان هذه الحركه الطبيعيه
تخفي المعاناه اقتصاديه معاناه معيشيه
معاناه نفسيه يعني تشاهدين الحزن على وجوه
الناس هنا الا ان هناك كلمه واحده يرددها
الجميع بانهم يريدون السلام ولكن ايضا
يريدون ان تنتهي هذه الحرب لصالح اوكرانيا
طبعا بالمؤشرات ساسكرها بطريقه سريعه جدا
هنا المدارس ما زالت مقفله بعد سنه من
الحرب التعليم ما زال عن بعد الجامعات
ايضا التعليم عن بعد كل الطلاب التي كانت
طلاب الابتعاد التي كانت يعني تاتي الذين
كانوا ياتون الى اوكرانيا اصبحوا بالدول
المجاوره اتحدث هنا عن بولندا عن كل الدول
المجاوره لاوكرانيا طبعا البطاله زادت
بشكل كبير بحركه المحاله التجاريه والشارع
هناك بعض المحل ما زالت مقفله حتى اليوم
هناك بعض المحل يعني عادت الى طبيعتها
الكثير ممن نزحوا ببدايه الحرب عادوا الى
كياف تحديدا طبعا يعني هي لم تشهد وسط
العاصمه معارك كما اطراف العاصمه وكما
المناطق الجنوبيه ولكن هناك خوف اساسي
اليوم لدى الناس وهو الخوف من عمليه جديده
عن طريق الجبهه الشماليه التي كنا
تابعناها بالفتره الماضيه وتحدثنا كثير
عنها عن جبهات بيلاروسيا صحيح كياف لم
تشهد معارك ضاريه الا في جوانبها ولكن
خاركيف حيث تتواجد احمد كانت محطه لمعارك
ميدانيه في قصف عنيف كذلك كيف هي الصوره
بعد عام على انطلاق هذه الحرب
نعم ريم اهلا بك يعني يبدو ان
المبنى الذي اقف امامه الان يمثل شاهدا
صريحا وواضحا على ما مر بهذه المدينه التي
تعد ثاني اكبر المدن الاوكرانيه بعد كيف
مئات الالاف من يعني تركوها واجبروا على
الهجره منها جراء هذا التدمير الهائل
والقصف الروسي المستمر بشتى انواع الاسلحه
يعني قبل قليل كنا نقف مع عمده خاركيف
يعني هذا هو العمده يمكن للكاميرا ان تنقل
لك عمده يتحدث مع بعض
المواطنين الذين جاءوا الى هنا هناك
تساؤلات حول هل هؤلاء يعني الذين هجروا من
بيوتهم وتركوا هذه المنازل الى ربما الى
اماكن اخرى في اوكرانيا او خارج اوكرانيا
كيف سيعود وكيف سترمم هذه البيوت هل ستترك
هذه المباني شاهده على عام كامل من الحرب
الدمار الذي اصاب هذه المدينه كلها اسئله
مطروحه لكن دعينا نتحدث عن ان الاشتراكات
ما زالت مستمره يعني سمعنا قبل حوالي ساعه
دوري سفرات الانذار في سماء
خاركيف ايضا كان هناك
حديث عن مقتل احد
المواطنين ايضا القياده العسكريه تتحدث عن
ان العمليات القتاليه خلال يومين القادمين
ستكون قويه للغايه من قبل الجيش الروسي
خاصه ان بوتين كما يقولون على حد زعمهم
يريد الحصول على اي مكسب استراتيجي كبير
وهذا المكسب ربما يكون في مخموت التي تقع
في مقاطعه دنيتك
الكثير من الهجمات الغارات الجويه تحدث في
الجنوب والشرق الاوكراني بصوره مستمره
ايضا وزاره التعليم اعلنت انها وجهت يعني
تعميما على جميع مدارس في اوكرانيا بان
يكون التعليم عن بعد خلال الايام القادمه
تحسبا لما قد يحدث خلال
الذكرى الاولى للحرب هذا ايضا يوضح له
دلاله واضحا ان هناك شعور لدى الجميع هنا
ان شيئا قويا سيحدث من جانب من قبل الجانب
الروسي
فقط دقيقه لك ودقيقه مع ليال سانهي بها
هذه المصافحه الاولى من الداخل الاوكراني
ليال دخوله الكياف ياتي بتزامن كذلك مع
زياره بايدن كان هناك بطريقه امنت بشكل
تدخل فيها الجانب الروسي كيف هي انطباعات
الاوكرانيين وسكان الداخل كييفي خاصه عن
هذه الزياره يتوقعون ينتظرون منها شيء
معين
يعني بطبيعه الحال منذ بدايه الحرب وحتى
الساعه واليوم يعني هذه الزياره تعتبر
رمزيه وسياسيه بمعنى كبير على بعد يعني
قبل ايام من ثانويه هذه الحرب الناس هنا
يقراونها بانها دعم كبير ولكن ايضا هناك
مخاوف من اطاله امد الحرب وهو ما يقلق
طبعا السكان الذين تعبوا بالرغم يعني من
من كل شيء هم تعبوا من هذه الحرب التي قضت
على على تفككت الاسره الاوكرانيه بشكل
كبير وايضا قضت على الاقتصاد الاوكراني
الذي ايضا كان يعاني اصلا قبل هذه الحرب
ولكن يعني اسمحي لي ان اشير
اننا التقينا ونحن في طريقنا الى هنا الى
كيف بموكب الرئيس الامريكي وهو مغادر من
من العاصمه الاوكرانيه الاجراءات الامنيه
كانت مشدده جدا على طول الطريق ويعني هنا
بهذه النقطه بالذات كانت مغلقه من كل
المداخل تحسبا لاي يعني ط وطبعا كما ذكرتي
كان هناك تنسيق مع الجانب الروسي حول هذه
الزياره منعا لاي خروقات امنيه طبعا من
عواقب كبيره على كل الجوانب صحيح وهذه
الزياره بدات هل يمكن ان تلقي بظلها على
موضوع التسليح انت في خركيز وخر كيف تشهد
اشتباكات وهناك انتظارات ملحه لتصليح من
نوع متطور اكثر من السابق ما الذي قالوه
لك بخصوص هذه النقطه
يعني القياده العسكريه هنا تقول انها
متفائله بصوره كبيره نتيجه الوعود التي
وعدت بها من قبل القاده والدعم المستمر من
قبل المسؤولين الذين يعني هذا الدعم واضح
من قبل الوصول المستمر للرئيس بايدن
بالامس واليوم ورئيسه الوزراء ايطاليا
هناك حديث عن دبابات لوبار 2 كذلك ايضا
ابرمز وكذلك تشالنجر الدبابات البريطانيه
انظمه رادار ودفاع وكذلك مضادات للدروع كل
هذه الاسلحه المتوقعه ان تصل قريبا الى
الى الاراضي والجبهات
القتال المختلفه في اوكرانيا لاسيما في
خار كيف التي يعني يبعد القتال عن هنا عن
المكان الذي نقف فيه حوالي عشرين كيلو
مترا لكن كما ذكرت لك الجميع من المواطنون
هنا يتخوفون او يريدون ان يكون هذا هذه
الوعود حقيقه في اقرب وقت ممكن لانهم
عانوا بصوره كبيره الخاسر والذي عنى بصوره
اكبر في هذه الحرب هم المواطنون الاوكران
الذين هجروا من بيوتهم واجبروا على تركها
الى اماكن اخرى ربما البعض يتوقع امدا
طويلا لهذه الحرب لان من الصعب طبعهم
يعرفون انهم الصعبه الانتصار على الجانب
الروسي لكنهم يريدون
لهذه الحرب ان تقف في اسرع وقت ممكن ولن
تقف هذه الحرب الا عندما يتم وجعه يعني او
يشعر الجانب الروسي بوجع نتيجه الضربات
التي يلحق به الجيش الاوكراني وهذا ربما
ستحدثه او سيحدثه الدعم العسكري الذي وعدت
به من قبل الجانب الاوروبي نعم على كل
سنبقى في متابعه كل ذلك اود شكركم جزيل
الشكر ولكن قبل
الختام او فقط العوده لبعض لحظات معك
العيال زملاء زادونا بعض الوقت مشكورين
لاسال عن وضع من هناك من حيث البروده انت
يعني
تحاولين ان تكوني ملابس ثقيله ولكن البعض
الاخر في داخل كييف مع انقطاع التيار
الكهربائي مع انقطاع كل الموارد القادره
على حمايته من قسوه البرد كيف يعيشون ما
الذي يفعلونه
اسمحي لي ان انقل الصوره فور دخولنا من
الحدود الاوكرانيه عندما قطعنا الحدود
البولنديه ووصلنا الى الحدود الاوكرانيه
كان ظلام قد حال بهذه النقطه الشوارع يعني
ظلام ظلام تام لا تستطيعين رؤيه اي شيء
لان التيار الكهربائي مقطوع بهذا الجانب
من اوكرانيا بشكل تام طبعا عندما تتقدمين
بوسط بالمناطق الداخليه اتحدث عن الفيف
مثلا هناك بعض الكهرباء ولكن بالسنتر يعني
فقط داخل المدينه عندما ايضا بالطريق
للوصول الى كياف ايضا ظلام تام سالت
الكثير من الاوكرانيين الذين التقيتهم
طبعا من يفهم اللغه الانجليزيه ومن استطعت
ان اترجم له بعض الكلمات كان الجواب واحد
نحن نعاني كثيرا من التقنين من البرد من
الصعوبه صعوبه العيش بالشتاء هنا بظل كل
الظروف التي يعني نمر بها هنا بالعاصمه
الاوكرانيه
تقريبا التيار الكهربائي عاد بنسبه 90 الى
95% بحسب المواطنين وبحسب ايضا السلطات
الرسميه ولكن بطبيعه الحال الازمه
الاقتصاديه يعني
وكل تبعات الحرب تثقل كاهل المواطنين ليس
لديهم القدره على العيش بمكانه يستطيعون
العيش به بالفتره الماضيه ما قبل الحرب
ومن هنا تاتي المعاناه يعني ممكن بشكل
واضح جدا انتريه على ملامح وجوه الناس
هناك حزن وكابه موجوده وواضحه لا تحتاج
لاي سؤال صحيح على كلا نحن سنتابع كل هذه
الجوانب ان كانت عسكريه سياسيه اقتصاديه
ظروف معيشيه وللعربيه تقطيع خاصه يوم
الجمعه في ذكرى السنه من هذه الحرب الجزيل
الشكر على كل ما تفضلتم به الاختيار
مفردات العربيه الى كييف واحمد بجاتو موفد
العربيه الى وعودوا لنا سالمين
الى فاصل من بعدها سنعود لنتابع
12 دوله اوروبيه تقول ان ادوات روسيا
للتحايل على العقوبات تزداد بطرق ابداعيه
ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد استقبل رئيس
البولندي اندريدا نظيره الامريكي جو بايدن
في وارسو واكدت رئاسه البولنديه ان
الجانبين سيناقشان تعزيز ان بولندا
والجناحه الشرقي لحلف الناتو ومن المقرر
ان يلقي بايدن كلمه من وارسو مساء اليوم
وقد اكد البيت الابيض انها لن تكون ردا
على خطاب بوتين ولن تشمل اي خطط لانهاء
الحرب في اوكرانيا عبر الدبلوماسيكا
عن هذه الزياره نسال زميلنا من وارسو
العربيه حسين قنيبر حسين اهلا بك معنا
اسمح لي قبل البدء بالحديث عن المضمون ان
نتحدث شكلا عن هذه الزياره جدول الاعمال
ابرز اللقاءات الامريكيه البولنديه التي
يمكن انتظارها في هذه المرحله
نعم يعني في الواقع الزياره تنقسم الى
قسمين هي تتالف من شقين الشق الاول بدا
قبل حوالي ساعتين من الان هنا في القصر
الرئاسي في وارسو وسيبدا الشق الثاني بعد
قليل في القلعه الملكيه في العاصمه
البولنديه هنا حيث انا موجود حيث يتجمع
عدد كبير جدا من البولنديين سيلقي امامهم
الرئيس الامريكي خطابا بعد حوالي ساعتين
من الان اذا شق رسمي بدا في القصر الرئاسي
وتمثل بلقاءات مع الرئيس البولندي وعدد من
المسؤولين البولنديين والشق الشعبي اذا
جاز التعبير وهو الذي سيتمثل في خطاب
للرئيس الامريكي فيه امام عدد كبير من
الناس هنا طبعا بعد الشق الرسمي قال
الرئيس الامريكي اثر لقائه نظيره البولندي
ان اوروبا يجب ان تكون امنه هذا امر منطقي
واساسي الحلف الاطلسي حلف الناتو هو اكثر
حلفا مترابط في العالم كما قال الرئيس
الامريكي فيما قال نظيره البولندي اندريه
دوده بعد اللقاء ان الزياره المفاجئه
للرئيس بايدن الى كيف رفعت معنويات الذين
يدافعون عن اوكرانيا لان اكبر حلفا في
العالم
وقائده الاكبر رئيس الولايات المتحده يقف
الى جانبهم تلك هي الاشاره التي ارسلتها
زياره بايدن الى كيف كما قال الرئيس
البولندي علما ان زياره الرئيس بايدن الى
العاصمه الاوكرانيه غيرت بل عدلت في
برنامج زيارته الى بولندا من منتظر من
كلمه بايدن بعد ساعتين من الان ونحن سنبقى
في انتظار هذه الكلمه
لنفهم هذه التصريحات البيض الابيض حسين
يقول بان هذه التصريحات لن تاتي
تصريحات بوتين لن يكون هناك رد بمعنى اخر
على بوتين ولن يكون هناك حديث عن حلول
دبلوماسيه او عن خطط تملكها واشنطن اذا
استثنينا هذين
الملفين ما المنتظر هل تسرب اي شيء بخصوص
هذه الكلمه
نعم التسرب من مصادر امريكيه من جهه
وبولنديه من جهه اخرى المصادر الامريكيه
تقول ان الرئيس بايدن سيركز على الحشد
الدولي الذي امنته الولايات المتحده لدعم
اوكرانيا في الاسابيع الماضيه فيما تقول
الحكومه البولنديه على لسان رئيس الوزراء
ان خطاب الرئيس الامريكي ستكون له ابعاد
دوليه هو سيؤكد من خلال خطابه على قوه
الردع التي يجب ان يتمتع بها حلف النيتو
وبالمناسبه فان الرئيس الامريكي الذي
يستكمل غدا زيارته للعاصمه البولنديه
سيلتقي غدا بممثلين عن مجموعه بوخارست
تسعه وهي مجموعه تضم تسع دول من اوروبا
الشرقيه تسع دول اعضاء في حلف النيتو هي
لو سمحت لي سريعا لان ذلك له دلالات معظم
هذه الدول كانت في الكتله الشرقيه المؤيده
للاتحاد السوفيتي سابقا هذه تشيكيا
سلوفاكيا بلغاريا استونيا ليتوانيا
ورومانيا وبلغاريا بالاضافه الى بولندا
البلد المضيف لهذا اللقاء غدا بين الرئيس
الامريكي وممثلين عن مجموعه بوخارست 9
انسحبت من المشهد قليلا لاترك الصوره
تتحدث عما هو حاصل هنا على هذه المنصه
سيلقي الرئيس الامريكي خطابه بعد حوالي
ساعتين من الان وهو خطاب ينتظره المئات من
البولنديين المحتشدين هنا في القلعه
الملكيه في وارسو والتي سيصل اليها الرئيس
الامريكي بعد ان يغادر القصر الرئاسي حيث
كان التقى بنظيره البولندي دوده قبل قليل
من الاندرويد
كذلك في مناقشه النقطه التي اتيت على
اسرها منذ قليل منذ قليل تحدثت عن بولندا
وعن مجموعه اخرى من الدول التي كانت تتبع
السوفيتي والتي كانت روسيا تتمنى ان تبقى
مستقطبه لها ولكن هذه الدول فيما بعد
انتقلت غربا
من بينها بولندا اصبحت تتبع حلف الناتو
بولندا الى اي مدى سنه من حرب اوكرانيا
تراها بشكل خاص غير بقيه الدول الاوروبيه
ربما
تماما من المفارقات اللافته جدا ريم ان
وارسو التي كانت تحمل اسم الحلف حلف
الكتله الشرقيه المؤيده للاتحاد السوفيتي
السابق في مواجهه حلف اخر هو حلف الناتو
وارسو نفسها هذه باتت اليوم قاعده رئيسيه
بل واجهه الحلف الخصم حلف الناتو الذي كان
يواجه حلف وارسو وارسو التي اصبحت في مكان
اخر مختلف تماما اهميه بولندا بالنسبه
لحلف الناتو وللولايات المتحده تحديدا ان
بولندا هي البلد الذي يعتبر حدود اوكرانيا
اولا مع الحلف الاطلسي وثانيا حدود
اوكرانيا مع الاتحاد الاوروبي فولندا هي
عضو في الاتحاد الاوروبي كما تعلمين وعضو
في الحلف الاطلسي ايضا بولندا هي بوابه
ايصال المساعدات التي تقدمها الاسره
الدوليه الى اوكرانيا بوابه وصول هذه
المساعدات العسكريه
الانسانيه الى اوكرانيا ثم ان بولندا التي
استقبلت ملايين اللاجئين عندما كنا عند
حدودها مع اوكرانيا قبل اقل من عام بل قبل
عام عندما اندلعت الحرب في اوكرانيا
بولندا هذه يقول الامريكيون انهم ماضون في
دعمها وهي طلبت من الولايات المتحده ان
يكون تواجد قواتها في بولندا تواجدا دائما
اكثر وباعداد اكبر وهو ما وعد به الرئيس
الامريكي وعد بان تكون بولندا في المستقبل
المقر الدائم لقياده عسكريه امريكيه جديده
في اوروبا الشرقيه على كل سنبقى في انتظار
كلمه رئيس الامريكي جو بايدن بعد اقل
تقريبا من ساعتين سنعود لك زميل حسين
قنيبر موفد العربيه الى وارسو شكرا جزيلا
ومشاهدينا في خضم هذا التصعيد بين واشنطن
وبيكين من جهه اخرى انتقدت الصين ارسال
الولايات المتحده لحزمه مساعدات عسكريه
جديده الى اوكرانيا وتعمل متحدث باسم
خارجيتها اتهم امريكا بانها تتكسب من
الازمه
الولايات المتحده هي اكبر مورد للاسلحه
الى ساحه المعركه في اوكرانيا امس اعلنت
الولايات المتحده عن 500 مليون دولار
كمساعدات عسكريه ذلك يجعل البعض يتساءل
عما تنوي الولايات المتحده فعله من خلال
الادعاء الكاذب بان الصين تقدم اسلحه تدعي
الولايات المتحده انها تحافظ على السلام
لكنها في الواقع تكسب المال من الازمه
هذا وكان شدد بيان غربي يدوم عشره دوله
اوروبيه على ان ادوات روسيا للتحايل على
العقوبات تزداد بطرق ابداعيه واكد البيان
على ان الاقتصاد الروسي تحول الى عسكري
بالكامل دعم جهود الحرب مطالبا بالضغط على
الدول التي تساعد روسيا والتي لا تلتزم
بهذه العقوبات كما شدد البيان الذي يضم 12
دوله اوروبيه على ضروره معاقبه كل من
يساعد روسيا على التهرب من العقوبات
الى ملفنا اخر الان وفي تدعيه زلزال
المدمر الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا في السادس
من فبراير الماضي اعلنت اداره الكوارث
التركيه ارتفاع عدد قتل الزلزال الذي ضرب
تركيا الى
42,310 قتلى من جهتي هكذا رايس التركي رشا
الطيبه اردوغان خلال تفاقده ولايه عثمانيه
على ضروره محاسبه المسؤولين عن الخسائر
الضخمه في الارواح جر الزلزال
هذه الكوار
ث
[موسيقى]
متابعه هذا الموضوع مع زمينا من هاتاي
موفد العربيه عبد القادر خربوش عبد القادر
اهلا بك معنا كنا نحدث اعداد القتلى من
وراء الزلزال الاول ولكن زلزال ثامن كذلك
اربك الجميع في الواقع شهدته تركيا بالامس
وسوريا واحسه وكل من اهالي فلسطين
ولبنان انت فيها تاي وهاتاي حاله ارتباك
كبيره داخل سكانها تبعناها بالامس كيف هي
صوره حتى الان
بالفعل حاله الارتباك لا تزال هي الابرز
على وجوه من تبقى فيها تاي لانه عندما
نقول من تبقى في هاتاي هاتاي تحولت الى
مدينه شبه مدينه اشباح لانه اغلب سكانها
ومن نجى منها غادر المدينه من هم بالخيام
في اطرافه على اطراف المدينه هم داخل
الخيام لا يغادرونها هناك حاله من الرعب
والخوف من مغادره الخيمه والتجول ربما في
الاحياء التي توجد بها مباني المباني كلها
مصدعه كلها يعني قد اكون بلغت ولكن
لم ابالغ كثيرا خلال جولاتنا طول اليوم
بهاتاي يعني اغلب البنايات مصدعه من صمدت
بينها من صمدت للزلزال الاكبر الذي ضرب
المنطقه في سادس من فبراير الماضي لم يصمد
للزلزال الاخير الذي ضرب مساء امس وهوى
صباح اليوم حاله
سعر مستمره لماذا اتواجد في هذه المنطقه
الهادئه هي قريه تبعد عن هاتاي بعشرين
كيلومترا تحولت الى قبله لمن عاشوا
بالمدينه وهم الان يبحثون عن نوعا من
الامان نشاهد حتى وكاله الطوارئ اداره
الطوارئ والكوارث التركيه نصبت خيمات في
هذه المناطق
والقرى الجبليه
لاستقطاب من يودون ان يقيموا مؤقتا في هذه
الخيام ممن اصبح لم يعد لهم ماوى
لاحظنا والتقينا بكثير من ممن فروا من
المدن الى هذه القرى خوفا من تكرار هزات
او زلزال جديد
يريدون النجاه بانفسهم يريدون الراحه ان
لا يشاهدوا تلك الاحوال معي الان احد
هؤلاء المواطنين وهم اتراك من اصول سوريه
ايضا قدموا الى هذه القريه نريد ان نعرف
منكم لماذا اخترتم القريه بدل البقاء في
المخيمات التي نصبت على اطراف المدينه
هنا يعني فينا ناخذ راحتنا بالطلعه
بالفوتي وشغله ثانيه اامن يعني من
باقي الاماكن يعني مدينه قرخان صفت صفت
خالي من السكان تماما
انتوا لستم بعيدين على مراكز الزلزال يعني
ما في زلزال هون في عم يصير زلازل وانما
امن من المناطق السكنيه العاليه اللي فيها
مباني عاليه هنكتبها خطره اكثر من هون
فردنا ان ناتي الى هذه القريه لانها يعني
تبقى امانا اكثر من هذيك المدن ذات
البنايات المباني بدا عن ظروف العيش في
هذه القريه في خيام رايناها لكن هل تصل
مساعدات ادويه ربما هناك جرحه ايضا قدموا
الى هذه القريه
تصل تصل ادويه تصل من المعونات لكن
لازم كمان يعني اكثر
اذا هذا هو المشهد من هذه القريه لم اتمكن
من حفظ
لقبها لانه الالقاب هنا صعبه شويه
نتابع كل هذه التفاصيل شكرا جزيلا لك عبد
القادر العربيه منها
سوريات يحكينا لحظات الرعب والهلع جراء
الزلزله المزدوج الذي ضربها جنوب تركيا
كل السكان البنايه نزلوا على الشوارع
وصار رعب وخوف يعني بكل السكان كل الاعزاز
صارت تخاف ونزلت مضى حدا شايف الوضع اذا
ضلينا عم نشعر بالخوف وعم يصير هزات
ارتداديه او هيك شيء راح ندور على خيام
ماوى نقعد فيه ايواء لبن ما يهدى الوضع ان
شاء الله كل العالم صار تصرخ خوف يعني
ورعب والعالم صارت تبكي وتصرخ ونزلوا ما
بيعرفوا كيف نزلوا والله يا خي كنا باركين
بامان الله
اصلي العشاء ما حسينا الا صارت
طلعنا رقد والله نحن بالطابق الارضي ماذا
يعني
يعني شلون طلعنا ما نعرف والله يعني صاير
فوقنا اربع طوارئ كمان يعني عم نخاف
مثل العالم اللي راحت يا عيني تحت الانقاذ
في نفس هذا الاطار كان نفى وزير الدفاع
التركي خلصي اقار وجود اي حركه لجوء من
سوريا باتجاه بلاده منذ وقوع الزلزال جنوب
تركيا في السادس من الشهر الجاري واكد
الوزير التركي في تصريحات عاقبه قيامه
بجوله تفقديه في المناطق المتضرره من
الزلزال بمدينه انطاكيا ان اكثر من 20 الف
سوريين عادوا الى بلادهم منذ وقوع
الزلزاله
مشاهدينا لتتوالى الازمات في سوريا فبعد
اسبوعين على الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب
الجنوب التركي وشمال السوري تلاح امس
زلزال اخر ما فقم حاله الهلع لدى السكان
وزاد الحاجه لمزيد من المساعدات في وقت لا
تزال السياسه تتغلب على الاوضاع الانسانيه
مساله تحرك المساعدات معقده منذ عام 2014
فيما كان النزاع السوري في اشده وخاصه
شمال غرب البلاد الخاضع لسيطره المعارضه
والذي يقتله اكثر من اربعه ملايين شخص رغم
تصاعد التوتر بين النظام والمعارضه انذاك
كانت المساعدات الامميه تمر لسوريا دون اذ
من دمشق عبر اربع نقاط حدوديه وهي باب
الهوى وباب السلامه الحدوديان مع تركيا
وليعروبيه باقصى الشرق على الحدود
العراقيه بالاضافه الى معبر الرمثا
الحدودي مع الاردن مع مرور الوقت واشتداد
الحرب تقلصات طرق اعداد تدريجيا الى معبر
باب الهواء فقط لمده سنين حتى وقوع
الزلزال الزلزال اندفع الامم المتحده الى
مطالبه النظام السوري باعاده فتح معابر
اضافيه غير باب الهوالي تسهيل وصول
المساعدات الى مناطق المعارضات دون قيد او
شرط ليتم الاعلان لاحقا عن فتح معبريه باب
السلامه من منطقه اعزاز شمال حلب والرعي
في ريف حلب امام مساعدتها لمده ثلاثه اشهر
بعدما حصلت على موافقته دمشق
هذا الموضوع مع من معبر باب الهوى الحدودي
مراسل العربيه محمد الاشقر محمد اهلا بك
معنا هل هناك فعليا دخول لمساعدات هل صارت
العمليه اسهل من الايام الاولى التي شهدت
صعوبات وشهدت عرقيل كذلك لمحاوله ايصال
هذه المساعدات الى هذه المناطق
نعم يعني فيها الحقيقه اخر قافله امميه
محمله بالمساعدات المقدمه من الامم
المتحده
دخلت اليوم عبر معبر باب الهوى حيث رصدنا
دخول 15 شاحنه محمله بالسلل الغذائيه ليصل
مجموع الشاحنات المحمله
باتجاه مناطق شمال غرب سوريا الى 210
شاحنات منذ بدايه هذه
نعم اللحظه طبعا دعيني ان اشير لك ان هناك
وفد اممي دخل اليوم عبر معبر باب الهوى
واتجه باتجاه المناطق المتضرره طبعا بحسب
الناشطين وشهود الاعيان قالوا انهم اتجهوا
الى مدينه حارم هذه المدينه التي نالت
نصيبها من الدمار والضحايا جراء الزلزال
المدمر الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا في السادس
من الشهر الجاري طبعا قبل قليل قبل ما
يقارب العشر دقائق غادر الوفد الاممي من
خلال معبر باب الهوى
طبعا بحسب
قالوا ان هذا الوفد وعد الاهالي الذين
التقى بهم بان يزيد المساعدات في الايام
القادمه ولكن الى
مساعدات ولكن محمد اذا سمحت لي الجهه
الاماميه هي التي تولى توسيع هذه
المساعدات او ان جهات اخرى تشرف على ذلك
باختصار ان تكرمت
نعم نعم
طيب الصوت يتقطع ساعتذر منك ولمشاهدينا
كذلك
نعود لك ربما في نشرات اخرى من امام معبر
باب الهوى الحدودي مراسل العربيه محمد
الاشقر شكرا لك
اخر الان حيث كشف مصدر سعودي لريتورس
كشفان السعوديه ستقوم اليوم بايداعي مليار
دولار في البنك المركزي اليمني ياتي ذلك
في وقت تكافح به الحكومه اليمنيه
ضعف العمله وارتفاع اسعار الوقود والسلع
الاوليه ومواجهه انعدام الامن الغذائي في
بلاده ويعاني اليمن ازمه اقتصاديه
وانسانيه حاده هي الاسوا في العالم بحسب
الاوم المتحده في ظل الحرب والفجوات
الحاده في التمويل والتضخم العالمي
والتاثير غير المباشر للحرب في اوكرانيا
تتوقف مع فاصل من بعد سنعود لنتابع
بالدموع وصيحه وداعي محبيها اليابان تعيد
باندا عملاقه لموطنها الاصلي في الصين
ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد اكد وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه ان الكره في ملعب
ايران للتعامل مع التحدي المتمثل في
برنامجها النووي واضاف في مؤتمر صحفي خلال
زياره لاسنا انا واشنطن لا تزال تعتقد ان
طريقه الاكثر فاعليه واستدامه للتعامل مع
هذا التحدي هي الدبلوماسيه وان في هذه
اللحظه فان هذه الجهود مؤجله لان ايران لا
تشارك بطريقه مجديه بحسب تعبيره واكد ان
الباب مفتوح دائما للمضي قدما في
الدبلوماسيه وانا الامر يتوقف على ما اذا
كانت ايران ستقرر المشاركه ام لا و السبت
الماضي دعا بيان لوزراء خارجيه امريكا
وفرنسا والمانيا وبريطانيا دعوا ايران الى
التراجع عن سياسه التصعيد النووي
في خذوني او غضون ذلك قال زعيم الجمهوريين
في مجلس الشيوخ الامريكيه ميتش ماكونيل
قال في مقابله مع العربيه ان واشنطن
ستواصل الضغط على ايران وفرض العقوبات
عليها لمنعها من امتلاك السلاح النووي
بدوري موطنها الاصلي في الصين بعد ان ظلت
في حديقه حيوان بالعاصمه اليابانيه طوكيو
قرابه سته اعوام وحظيه
شعبيه كبيره في حديقه حيوان اوينو في
طوكيو مولدها هناك بهذا ننهي نشره شكرا
على المتابعه والسلام عليكم
[موسيقى]